okay so this was a tough year to settle
on our number one game because there
were about five or six that people had
pretty strong arguments for we've
obviously announced the other nine in
our top ten but SEC ero shadows died
twice from from software
[Music]
Oh mother she'll certainly do a night on
you
[Music]
[Music]
more you argue very heavily for it so
I'm not it to you why is this game so
special I think the obvious parts of it
are things that are going to be
elaborated on by Jake and Lucy and Mike
like the kind of the feel of the
gameplay it feels like a sharp
satisfying mechanically rewarding game
that you don't it has a learning curve
that feels really really engaging you
start off feeling like you're on the
back foot as your character does and
then over time you build a kind of
verbage and understanding of the
language of the game and then as you go
deeper and deeper in you understand it
better but the game continues to
challenge you and your understanding of
that game so like that's core
fundamentally what makes Secura are so
special i feel like it's the best
playing game we've had this year but for
me the stuff that really really takes it
onto it different level is something
that i as we discussed like I feel like
doesn't get enough credit and that's the
story and the characters and the
narrative nuance that goes into it one
of the things that is difficult in
having that discussion is like Dark
Souls like blood-borne from software is
all about almost not not pointing out
front and center they do it through
nuance and it's weird because Sakura is
perhaps the most straightforward story
and we're going to subtleties yeah they
work insult ease but their stories are
always quite large and sprawling where
there's clearly a main arc but it's a
very simple one and you have to really
go around the like the peripheral and
find the items and speak to the
characters to piece that all together so
it makes sense so it feels like a rich
rewarding story as a whole this feels
like a more straightforward story if you
just play the main quest and it feels
like a a kind of like a complete story
in that regard however if you do delve
into the side stuff and speak to
characters and consider the themes more
I think it's as impactful as some of the
other stories that they've told
particularly the thing that stands out
about to me to me about this game is
this a game about death it's a game
about the impact of death well for you
guys I did
literally the main mechanic if you have
to die I was really good when you talk
about so death and like the impact of it
is what's important one because you as a
player it unless you make mihari in
which by which I mean a callous liar you
will die and the kind of the story of
you and how you rise to the challenge
facing that death and is as impactful as
the story being told in the game and
also parallels what's happening in game
fights like a natural for example that
cycle of life and death and whether you
continue to kind of engage it hoping to
to overcome the challenges is what is
quarter from Software's games right but
they have never explored it outside of
the mechanical way before whereas in
this game when you die there's stuff
like Dragon Rock which impacts other
people and effectively the more you died
the more cancerous dragon rock becomes
the people around you and the people
you've met and the more kinds of
dissipates around the world and what I
was saying during our discussion was
sure you could take that as a mechanical
thing but if you consider it what what
the impact of that is it feels a lot
more like it has more gravitas and the
impact of that is like you engaging with
this cycle of life and death is
effectively robbing life from other
people you're taking to live out your
destiny and tell your story and
have your story you're robbing other
peoples of their stories yeah it's like
a clever way of putting an actual
consequence to respawning exactly the
other games have done it in the past but
I feel like this was definitely an
impactful we're do it and that's I feel
like more so than Dark Souls any of the
three Dark Souls more so than
blood-borne the narrative being told
through writing and characterization and
the narrative and and the themes
explored through that as well as how
they manifest in gameplay and your own
struggle with the game are in such good
harmony that it makes it for I feel like
this one of the strongest and from
software games so far in terms of
narrative achievement and that just
takes the mechanical side of it and
elevates it for me but a more surface
level or a mechanical level I guess like
you had mentioned kind of how the
storytelling differs from From
Software's games and it's not the combat
itself is not just interesting in the
portfolio from software I said like even
in a year with like DMC five I said SEC
euro is still I think the best combat
system this year
you see when you were playing through it
how did that combat like what like what
are some of the nuances of combat that
made it so singular and special for you
I think because it gave you like time
was talking about this at length
yesterday and so I'm gonna kind of
paraphrase what you were saying but you
saying that basically it forces you to
master this one thing very specifically
and whereas in other firm software games
and certainly other role-playing and
action games you get given more often
than not this Arsenal and you can sort
of pick and choose how you approach
things whereas in Socorro it's very much
you need to learn to do this this way
and I think I can probably speak for a
lot of people with that when you first
play that game you get your ass handed
to you a lot because you are trying to
do things a different way I always
trying to play it like it was
blood-borne and that is just a mistake
but then I don't think there's a feeling
of success like the moment that Sakura
clicks with you and I remember when I
had that moment and I was like maybe an
hour in to a playthrough I was doing and
I ended up just sitting there for six
hours and just non-stop just racing
through it because it finally clicked
for me and I was finally just feeling
this immense sense of accomplishment and
like I think as incredible as the world
building is is incredible as a story
isn't how subtle and how beautiful
really everything is nothing for me
compares to that moment they obviously
get that every time you'd be a boss or a
very particularly difficult
enemy but I think the moment where
everything clicks is something just
profoundly very special yeah because
it's also not like you mentioned how it
differs from blood-borne blood-borne is
very much about dodging until you find
an opening there's more knee went snow
once to it than that but to describe in
a nutshell it's very much evasion and
kind of just like chipping away at an
enemy whereas SEC euro is more you need
to get up in someone's face whether you
are like prepared to or not like you
mentioned get Ichiro and I probably
tried him 40 times one night and then
finally when I went back with like
knowing how to fight him more but also
like knowing oh you got to be at certain
point you're gonna be relentless and
just break down his posture so he opens
up and then you can get the death blow
I really really enjoyed how it is so
counterintuitive to just like how you
play video games in general not just
from software's and you were talking
about how it just like made you feel
like more confident than like many other
games have yeah I mean I played through
that I played through Sakura probably
four or five times because I was trying
to get the Platinum and I ended up doing
it but I think for me the most
satisfying thing about that game was
when I got in there didn't yeah I did I
had to get it in there somehow but when
I replayed the game and I knew exactly
what I was doing and I would just
trounce bosses that took me hours to
beat before and then I'd go there like
oh yeah the Guardian eight you were a
threat not man and then I just smacked
him down and move on to the next one and
I was just so satisfying and I like I
still think about man I got to replay
that game because I think I can even
beat those bosses quicker and I'm
excited to to just engage in that world
again yeah and this there's a lot to be
said for that type of experience it's
not something that is common these days
like games these days are all about open
endedness interpretation letting the
player give the player enough to do what
they want to do and letting them find
the fun in that instead of creating a
very specific path and very specific
toolset that needs to be used in a
specific way by the developers and
designers and then trusting your player
to figure out what that is and then
encouraging them or challenging them to
raise their skills to meet that like you
you are you're building and
understanding with from software and
this and the designers of the game when
you're learning to play that game you're
literally putting yourself in the
mindset of a designer well I like you
fight a boss like you know the ball
organic hero or Lady butterfly you are
effectively peering into the coding at a
certain point and understanding what
does this animation mean what does this
movement mean how do i time my strike so
it deflects off that strike and I create
the opening you're like unpacking
this this character design and
mechanical design so then you can see
into it and figure out how to exploit it
and this varies a lot of satisfaction in
reaching that state of harmony again
with a developer or a designer that has
a very specific for and mindset for a
for a world for a character for a for an
experience yeah you mentioned some
several bosses we brought up getting
Ichiro lady butterfly the garden
Guardian thank you then the sunken
Valley yeah
the boss is in this game in like from a
developer that's pretty well known for
its bosses I feel like the bosses in
this game really embraced that fighting
game mentality where it's the way you
the way you beat lady butterfly is very
very different than the way you be the
bull the way you beat the bull is very
very different from the way you have to
be you can eat your ohh and that really
struck me because they're like nuances
to a lot of blood-borne bosses and
they're like but I felt like most from
software bosses despite them being
amazing in their previous games I felt
like it was often more like do I want to
dodge close to him or do I want to block
and then like dodge away from her what's
her reach like this is like no lady
butterfly you're like just being
defensive for me I don't the way I beat
her which again like there's not too
much variance between how you beat these
bosses it's like I defend for a while
and then that one moment that she jumps
up I throw a shuriken at her and I get
an opening if I'm quick enough but it's
like this game embraces teaching
discipline yeah more than its
funny-looking like you mentioned like
open-endedness is so huge and games
looking back at GameSpot's games of the
year we clearly were embracing that like
witcher 3 i guess over watching like how
many different characters there and ways
they're out of play
breath the wall about yeah they're all
about like how these systems kind of
unfold and you get those anecdotes this
game is more about here's this really we
think and know it's a powerful way and
you said I'd kind of like put you in
harmony with the designer and I will and
I like that because I am I was like
alright I know how to beat Kenichiro I
don't even I'm not even excited to even
try any other way I'm just gonna like
I'll be calm next time and control my
panic and I'll go in and I will just
like it's they don't get easy but in a
way they kind of do it's like oh I just
was doing that the whole time I should
have just been more relaxed it's you I
feel like what happens is you learn to
trust yourself and you learn to you go
through the pains of learning what needs
to be done and that's a quote at the
very start of the game that Okami says
which is like do what must be done no
speak your door
I must and that kind of defines every
interaction that you have in their game
he says that the Kuro but like it's what
he's saying to you as a player do what
must be done and what must be done is
face your face the Challenger and find
the right moment to strike and every
boss is about that that that journey of
understanding that you need to do what
must be done and that is like learn what
the boss is going to do figure out how
you counter to it and then trust
yourself to go into that engagement and
trust your skills that you will be able
to do it I also had trouble with Guinea
char or I reviewed the game and I played
it pretty much for 40 hours straight and
janitor Oh still stands as the hardest
boss fight I've had in a long time and I
end that review by revealing like it
took me six hours and when I did it it
was because I finally trusted myself it
was champagne it was yeah I cried
genuinely and it was because like mom it
was because I wasn't trying
half-measures I wasn't doing the thing
where I was like I couldn't see an
opening here I'm gonna go in and strike
I was effectively told myself I've
played fine games all my life I have the
muscle memory and the reaction times to
do this and I don't need to be afraid of
what's happening and I got in there and
that's when I succeeded and the amazing
thing is like after you do that one boss
fire the sense of confidence that you
have going forward is just incredible
like you feel like you own that wall for
a good few hours until you reach another
point when they put another boss there
and they undermine your your knowledge
or challenge that knowledge or your your
mastery of those skills like the
guardian ape the Guardian is exactly and
like it keeps doing that it's it's
forcing you to understand those
designers the mechanics and how it's all
been constructed from so many different
angles that when you reach the final
boss that's when you understand that
everything that you have all the angles
you've been you've been tackling
different bosses from and all the
challenges presented is to prepare you
for that boss that one character funny
we talk about this game and we don't
really talk about how it's actually like
it's not a stealth game I wouldn't
say but there are stealth elements and
like they really encourage you to play
like the the ninja myth like do dirty
stuff throw a firecracker at this dude
to blind them for a little bit or sneak
up behind someone and backstab them and
throw ash in people's face yeah it's
like you can do all the dirty moves that
you see like that like villain halfway
through of an action we'll be doing
before you get can't stand yeah yeah had
to be said
but no the I I also really enjoyed that
they kind of went with stealth because
it's almost like they're like we know
people like sometimes we'll cheese a
boss if they are get lucky enough for
the game - not even the game just like
break if there's some weird little thing
you can do it's like in this game they
almost embraced that they're like here
will let you cheese this mob will give
you ways to do it makes it worse
honestly like how it like when you first
start out you're like okay I can stealth
oh this oh yeah I can take off one of
the critical hits by stealth thing and
then they turn around and they're like
alright now it's time to actually fight
and then you get your ass kicked until
you finally like you're saying until you
finally understand the language and
finally just go all in as opposed to
kind of doing this half half in Sakura
style half of blood-borne or Dark Souls
what was the what's the seven spheres
mini-boss solution seven spheres or a
sheen on those shoes man he took me
forever and I kept forever I was going
down the cliff to come up behind for the
first stealth death blow and then
finally I was like at the time I decided
to just practice with the time I finally
killed him I didn't you meet kiri
countess yeah oh I got those perfectly
and then also when he did the wide swipe
those like oh that's a jump and then
I'll do the kick on his head and that's
gonna lower or raise his posture
breakage or everyone call it even more
it's the speed at which you can read
enemies is just like amplified so much
toward you
the other part of what we've come to
expect from software are like intact and
done exceptionally well in this game you
know the the atmosphere of the world and
the physical construction of that world
you know there's always been that the
you know people talking about a lord run
and the the way it kind of falls in on
itself and that kind of stuff and that's
that's hearing in like plenty of
situations planning of every every part
of that map folds in itself and one of
the things I said in my review is like
it's immediately more visible because of
the way the areas are constructed it's
not like these massive massive
landscapes that eventually touch on each
other it's like you can see how each
individual area collapses in itself it
tree branches going on to roofs and
roofs overhanging stealth points and
that kind of stuff and areas to hide
yourself that kind of microcosm of what
everything from software does it feels
more tangible and more graspable for
people like general people you don't
have to be a from software fan and
really there was that it's the period
where people were really really like
well if you were from software fan you
almost saw something different in the
game than most people did you know you
had to really dedicate yourself I feel
like Sakura is the game that anyone can
play and understand why people are
obsessed with from software games and
what makes them special yeah I mean like
it's it's kind of like not auteur theory
it's that team right like it's it's if
you go into like seeing that your first
denis villeneuve movie you're gonna
maybe you'll you'll love it just like
everybody else did but like when I saw a
rival I understood it in his portfolio
and it kind of impacted me on two fronts
I thought Sakura was really cool in that
way because it felt like from software
kind of doing some self-examination yeah
especially because like aside from
blood-borne I personally felt like Dark
Souls as they went on they kind of
exhausted new ideas and I think three it
this might be a great game fantastic
game I still think it did it was like
okay kind of getting tired of this it
didn't it the Wonder yeah
I put it in my review like this was the
game that served as a reminder that from
software hasn't lost its teeth like
they're sharp as ever and they can make
you feel terrified in a way that few
other games haven't and during our
discussion I remember and in our review
I say it like the last time I truly felt
like this way like completely points
scared to move forward in a game was
demon souls and since that game the
first arguably the first from software
game of that kind of lineage of that ilk
nothing has replicated that until Sakura
and it's so unique a feeling and so you
know singular in its in its kind of
achievement that I feel like when it
it's a miracle that it was repeated mhm
and the fact that it has I feel needs to
be celebrated yeah we could talk for
hours about the game it's like like I
said there was like there are five or
six games that people I mean I think
everybody had a ask ten people what
their favorite game was this year
they'll have ten different answers but
Sakura was the one where people who
loved it were super passionate and even
the people who tried in the bounce-off
were like no I see why it's pretty a
powerful game and yet for people who
haven't played it they absolutely should
but uh yeah that was I have no qualms
about being our game of the year
agreed yeah we know
you